the Golden Age of classic western films
may be over but a new kind of Western
has established its place in the world
of prestige TV whether you're a huge fan
already or just getting into it is
everything we know so far about
Yellowstone season three by the
Yellowstone season two finale
Casey Dutton and Monica's son Tate had
been kidnapped and the Dutton's were on
a mission to bring him home at any cost
they tracked down teal and Malcolm back
knowing that the true businessman have
something to do with the disappearance
heaven this is your last chance to do
something just might get you in it
teal Martin confess so Casey makes good
on John's promise to shoot him Malcolm
is willing to give up some details but
he suffers a few gunshot wounds in his
presumably left for dead it turns out
that Tate has been kidnapped by white
supremacists who were hired by the backs
by the time Casey finds him he's already
been beaten and traumatized but with the
mystery of his abduction solved he can
finally return home in a heartwarming
moment John's daughter Beth reads his
right-hand man ripped wheeler a letter
from John explaining that he's leaving
rip his father's old ranch house in
exchange for saving Beth from a pair of
attackers Keith [ __ ] paramount Network
and TV land president of development and
production says the network has grand
visions for season three and beyond and
he's impressed with the scripts that
he's read so far
he told deadline it's going to be great
and even bigger than season two I know
it I feel it it will happen Cox also
says that the final ending for the
series is already planned discussions
about an eventual season four are
ongoing and the show will ideally run
for six or seven seasons total Costner
has made it clear that there will be
further consequences for those who
threatened the Dutton family in season
two so it looks like karma will be
coming around meanwhile Beth and rip
appear to be diving back into their
rekindled romance fan theories abound
regarding Jaime's possible past
interference in their relationship
so perhaps season three will address
some of those rumors but expect some big
changes going from season two into
season three you can try to find a way
to play it safe there isn't the cost has
noted that season three will start off
slow but it won't stay that way for long
it's a slow burn now and then it heats
up fans who are worried that the show
won't feel quite the same can rest
assured that they're in for a great
season season three is some of my
favorite stuff so far it's pretty
shocking it looks like all of the main
cast members appear to be returning for
Yellowstone season three naturally you
won't be seeing Terry Serpico as teal
anymore but there's still a slim chance
that neal mcdonough could return as
malcolm remember he didn't actually die
on camera this season a few other
recurring actors will be bumped up to
regular roles for EJ Smith who plays
Dutton's cow boss Lloyd is officially
being promoted to a series regular along
with Denham Richards who plays cowboy
Wrangler coldly it's safe to say we'll
be seeing a lot more of lloyd and colby
in the upcoming season kevin costner may
be stepping behind the camera on
occasion throughout this season as well
in a recent interview with deadline
Costner expressed his hope that he would
be able to focus on directing in the
future Josh Holloway will be appearing
as rock Carter a charismatic hedge fund
manager with big plans in Montana plans
that just might involve the Dunn ranch
Holloway has described his character as
quote a hedge-fund baller with Costner
adding you can't ignore it we can't just
kind of close the gate deadline notes
that Holloway's character will have a
season long arc so it doesn't look like
he'll be sticking around for a probable
season four it's hinted that Carter
might try to make a move on Beth and
Kelly Reilly expressed excitement at
working with Holloway perhaps Carter is
trying to take control of the land for
himself and wants to curry favor with
Beth as in in with the Dutton's well
maybe he'll prove to be an unlikely ally
for the Dutton's in the face of another
adversary John Emmett Tracy is also
slated to appear in a recurring role as
Ellis steel a chief litigator for
fortune 500 companies described as quote
the kind of person who will smile as he
stabs you in the back Steel could pose a
serious threat to the Dunn ranch quarry
Anka Kilcher will be playing Angela blue
thunder a Native American woman who
opposes Tom rainwater the chief of the
reservation angela is disgusted with the
way rain water has been running the
casino and she feels that he's
responsible for many of the problems on
the reservation whether or not Angela's
bold action against rainwater will
benefit the Dutton's is unclear but
considering his past intentions to
acquire their land to expand the
reservation the enemy of their enemy
might be their friend
in this scenario working with them as a
deal with the devil dead all the angels
are gone son there's only Devils left a
new Wrangler will be working on the
Dutton ranch in season three Jennifer
Landon is joining the cast as Tita an
accomplished Wrangler who may be a bit
rough around the edges but always gets
the job done it's likely she'll be
working alongside Colby and Lloyd Tina
won't be the first female ranch hand to
work for the Dutton's after all Avery
was already recruited to work there by
ripp in the first season but it does
look like she'll be just the kind of
no-nonsense woman who could hold her own
on the ranch
Eden Brolin will be another addition to
the cast she has a recurring role as Mia
a barrel racer who strikes up a
friendship with the bunkhouse guys
Brolin is most widely known for playing
Charlie in the freeform series beyond in
which a young man awakens from a coma to
find that he has inexplicable powers
connecting him to a dark conspiracy her
work on Yellowstone is just another sign
that she's definitely a star on the rise
and one to watch in the next year
finally Karen Pittman is confirmed to
have a major role in season three she'll
be playing Willa Hayes the CEO of Metro
capital she's well-dressed intimidating
and never backs down from what she wants
now she wants something from John Dutton
and she's going to fight to
denial to get it there's a possibility
that Ellis teal is representing her as
she tries to acquire the Dutton's land
with so many new female characters
coming to the ranch
it looks like the women will be running
thanks overall it's shaping up to be an
incredible follow-up to an addictive
second season you can catch up on the
first two seasons of Dutton family drama
on amazon prime season three of
yellowstone premieres and the paramount
network On June 17 2020 tech out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]